the eyes are our windows onto the world
by far the most sophisticated component
of the eye is the retina the thin layer
of tissue at the back that converts
light into chemical and electrical
signals sadly it's estimated that by
2020 almost 200 million people will lose
their sites because of diseases of the
retina age-related macular degeneration
or amv is the most common retinal
degenerative disease and there is
currently no cure the retina contains
five distinct types of neurons which are
wired together into one of nature's most
bewildering circuit boards this
circuitry is kept healthy by a thin
layer of cells called the retinal
pigment epithelium or RPE the RPE forms
a honeycomb structure sandwich tightly
between the photoreceptors and a
basement membrane this RPE layer
transports nutrients from the blood to
the retina and hoover's up the toxic
byproducts created by the photoreceptors
as they react to light once these RPE
cells are damaged they don't regenerate
meaning they can no longer support the
photoreceptors the macula is the part of
the retina with the highest
photoreceptor concentration when the
photoreceptors here start to die
detailed vision needed for tasks like
reading begins to disappear irreversibly
over the past decade scientists have
been edging closer to recreating parts
of the retina in the lab the most
advanced area of research involves
replacing damaged RPE cells with new
cells created from stem cells and there
are two main approaches currently in
clinical trials the first involves
injecting a suspension of these new stem
cell derived RPE cells directly into the
retina this technique has worked in
animal models and has been shown to be
safe in humans but some researchers are
doubtful about the ability of these
free-floating new cells to organize into
the tightly packed well-ordered layer
required to form a functioning RPE the
alternative approach is to inject the
new stem cell derived RPE as a fully
formed layer
clinical trials on for patients have
reported some early success using these
preformed sheets with two patients
reporting improvements in their vision
but larger trials are necessary while
researchers are trying to perfect the
use of sheets of cells in clinical
trials for such as in the lab are making
progress recreating fully formed 3d
miniature retinas one day these mini
retinas might be a one-stop shop for new
transplantable retinal tissue and cells
including photoreceptors they might also
make perfect models to examine how rare
genetic diseases affect retinal
development and could shed light on how
individual patients will respond to
drugs as our understanding of the retina
and how to regenerate it comes into
clearer focus therapies for diseases
like age-related macular degeneration
may soon be in sight
[Music]
you